[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews where I speak to people who
have something to say about the world
today and how it's changing this week
two leaders in their professions with
strong views on the biggest stories of
the moment the NHS and Trust in policing
foreign
Lord Winston has dedicated much of his
work in life to health care and is
alarmed by the current crisis in the NHS
he says the government's lost control
needs to increase funding and workers
pay to stop the strikes making it worse
and Britain's fast black police and
crime commissioner Festus akamba Sawyer
on why it's time to take complaints
against officers more seriously to rid
the force of criminals plus how he's
dealt with racist abuse for being a
conservative
fast though the world-renowned
embryologist Lord Winston now in his 80s
he spent decades in healthcare and says
the current NHS crisis is the worst he's
seen so what Solutions should the
government be looking at
Lord Winston thank you for coming on our
show today now the NHS is never out of
the headlines at the moment and the
thing I wanted to start off asking you
is how big a crisis do we find ourselves
in today when it comes to our Health
Service
I think it's a very real very serious
crisis I don't think we've certainly
I qualified in medicine in 19
8 uh not even
64 and there's never been a crisis like
that since
um and I think it's a bit like a battle
you know when you start to lose control
of the battle that's when it gets really
bad and what's happened now of course is
the government's actually lost control
what do you mean when you say they've
lost control
well when you have ambulances clearly
outside hospitals when you've got people
dying unnecessarily unfortunately when
you see people with heart attacks and
with cancer not being treated on time I
mean that is actually losing control of
healthcare so when Kirsten says he
thinks it's the worst crisis in the
nhs's history he's not making a
political point you don't think you
think that that is the truth I'm sure
you know I I know I sit on the labor
benches in the House of Lords but you
know really I see myself really as more
of a cross-bench in mind and but I mean
kirst armor is absolutely right he's
completely trustworthy and I don't have
any doubt that really what he's saying
is really from the heart and and Lord
Winston the government you know I talk
to ministers about this and to number 10
about what's going on they often talk
about the legacy of covid that that has
compounded the problems that's created
these huge waiting list people not going
in uh to see doctors during those two
years where the pandemic really absorbed
the whole attention not just of the
country but the Health Service obviously
that there is some truth in that isn't
it it's not it's not entirely I would
put it in a different way I would say
that the government have been incredibly
lucky with kovid because actually in
fact it delayed it this in fact gave
them a perfect excuse not to do things
and they've been sitting complacency
while this has been going on so covert
has directed everything and actually so
you this is this crisis was inevitable
without covered there's no question
about that it was it was absolutely yeah
if you look at the graphs of everything
going on they're going off almost in a
linear fashion waiting lists ambulance
problems people dying people not getting
diagnoses right the way through for
years before covered so this has been a
long-term problem and it's been going on
at least for 10 12 years probably longer
and it's been clear that there has been
massive underfunding of the house Health
Service so Lord just to be clear your
view is that covid has given the
government cover to blame underlying
problems no question and in fact don't
forget they were warned about coven we
had the select committee I sit on in the
House of Lords at Science and Technology
had repeatedly pointed out there was
bound to be a pandemic when kirst armor
then says
I don't want to talk about funding that
is dishonest isn't it because isn't that
partly what a political leader should
talk about and it was disingenuous to
say it's all about reform it doesn't
need more money I'm not prepared to say
that kirstana's dishonest if he says I'm
not going to talk about the funding it
may be because his views on the funding
are currently fluid right and in fact I
think that actually we should have that
fluid View and I think that's reasonable
and I think in fact if we ever get round
to having a
cross party agreement it's not going to
come very easily because neither side is
going to want to sit down like this
because actually whoever does this could
lose a huge number of votes but actually
we have to start thinking not
politically but actually in terms of
what really is needed and that's a very
big difference sort of thinking the
unthinkable yes look we know from the
first world war if you fight a battle
politically you lose it and that's what
the politicians did on both sides large
numbers of lives are lost on the German
and the English side because the
politicians were trying to direct the
war and actually this is the same sort
of thing we've got to really look about
what is really needed in terms of
managing a proper Healthcare System do
you personally think that the NHS does
need
more resource and more funding yes
people are scared about talking about
this aren't they because they're wary
that reform is code for diluting the
principle of the NHS being free for all
this is a political issue isn't it in
that sense it's a issue we should deal
with with some humility isn't it that's
really what we need to do and actually
recognize that nobody has a perfect
answer but actually one thing we could
certainly do is to look at systems which
are better than our NHS you know for
years we have boasted the NHS is the
best best healthcare system in the world
doctors will tell you that it's not the
doctors who go outside this country and
many of them do I've worked in the
United States I've worked in Europe I've
had jobs in Belgium for example I've
been in the front line in other
countries and actually there are many
examples across Europe in particular but
also elsewhere where in fact there is
better care than we're giving and we
have to understand ourselves what have
we done that could have been done what
do we do now to try and do that it means
a change in the way that we do things it
doesn't mean to say that we don't want
to see health care for everybody of
course we do that is perfect a
reasonable proper entitlement in a good
democracy but it needs to be done
fearlessly and it's going to have to be
very difficult to do I don't do I don't
doubt that Lord would I actually
interviewed sadri Javid the former
Health secretary at the end of last year
and we touched upon this and he said
we need to talk about the funding of the
NHS and then I said well what particular
model do you like France do you like
Germany what are you looking at and he
didn't want to discuss that and he
basically said that no one can talk
about this because they are shouted down
I think you're saying that that needs to
end but do you accept that that probably
cannot happen until after a general
election you know what that's what
happened to me in the year 2000 when I
was shuttered down by Aleister Campbell
and Tony Blair came back on the phone
and said you know you're quite right
we're going to increase the funding
and he did massively and of course they
had a very large majority May well be
that the next government will have a
very large majority is this a call to
care start with that in a way to kind of
show yes I would I would love to talk to
Kira because I I have a huge regard for
him now at the moment it's very clear
that this government is burnt out
so there's every reason why we should be
thinking about what we would do if we
did have a massive majority and start to
attract us with that you talked about
other assists other countries use hybrid
systems of Public Funding and private
insurance is that what you think the UK
needs well I'll tell you what you know
had we done what I wanted
um when the labor government was in
to really bring Private Practice into
the NHS hospital so that we had not
private clinics in Holly Street but
private clinics actually in our main
Central hospitals and really where
Consultants no longer had to drive out
to a private Clinic that would go next
door and you wouldn't have a
differential treatment because they
wouldn't treat patients differently but
you there are still hospitals where that
happens for example but on the whole it
doesn't really happen very much another
huge amount of income has been lost as a
resulting consequence because of a Dogma
associated with private practice just in
terms of other other areas of reform
because laboratory talking about
reorganization Kirsten has suggested
more self-referral now you are a
practice you know you were a
practitioner you're an expert do you
think that's a good idea that that the
people self-refer is that just time
wasting because it's unwise with unwise
referrals I think it's something I said
people with self-bleeding internal
bleeding could well I mean don't you
need to go to a e if you've got into but
I think it's difficult to understand
quite what he meant but I mean if you
meant if you meant that you know just
being aware of symptoms earlier and then
for doing something about it yeah I
would agree with that if you mean
self-fulfill in terms of how most
doctors seem to perceive it and you saw
them on the news they were horrified
um I'm not clear quite what he had in
mind to be fair and I think that's quite
important too but we should have more
Health Care information available and I
think we do need a more robust Primary
Care system and at the moment that's not
adequate either so for example we have
very good General Practitioners but more
and more people as soon as they get to a
reasonable age
leave so that the the loss of retention
of workers in the Health Service is
scandalous and it's because of the very
poor circumstances and the fact that
they're not actually having any not
being listened to it well actually took
it and I was I might as well bring it
this up now I mean now you've brought it
up uh just quickly I I don't want to
make this into a news interview but
nurses pay doctors pay ambulance workers
pay does the government need to move on
this yes you think they do
of course we're not we're not paying
nearly enough
and is that affecting retention I mean
what well I'm out the argument about you
know if a nurse can walk out of a prime
an HS Hospital one day and walk into a
private Clinic the next day with a
increase not only a not really increased
salary but just better working
conditions being treated in a more human
way I mean but having having working
hours which are which are acceptable and
being able to work part-time perhaps
whatever it might mean I mean we've not
been that flexible we've been better at
that but if you talk to if you talk to
well you saw the nurses on the news
yesterday it makes you cry to see them
crying to see them shouting and
screaming in that sort of way that kind
of angst that is not usually shown by
nurses and doctors feel that just as
much but they probably don't say it
quite so loudly
I I think there's been a great deal that
could be done with pay certainly a
pension reform is really urgently needed
that's clearly enough inequitous but
there are other things that could be
done as well yeah I think we have to pay
people what their value what their value
to society is and we value the NHS
square and we value the NHS greatly that
means that we have to actually consider
what is really worth to us and and Lord
Winston labor this week also revealed
figures showing that 37 000 people with
conditions like a tax or heart attacks
or Strokes a category two callers it's
described waited more than three and a
half hours for an ambulance in December
I mean what happens if you know they
what happens I mean you you I don't know
but if you have to wait an um an hour
for an ambulance and you've got a
suspected stroke or heart attack what
happens to that person well you lose
part of your brain which dies possibly
and of course you then have irreparable
damage so you are a much bigger cost of
the Health Service the rest of your life
which may be diminished of course
so when you see those ambulance Figures
it's not saving money it's actually
costing money it's actually costing
money to keep stroke people waiting yes
nobody's ever said that before but it's
obviously true
well so you're what would your just to
finish off and thank you for for
spending so much time talking to me but
what's your message then to political
leaders right now well I would like to
just hear honestly I think I'd like to
see honesty at the dispatch box and when
they ask questions we're not getting
that enough I think we all have to be
honest because nobody has the answers
and I think we really need a degree of
humility we can't just keep on boasting
about Healthcare there are pockets of
really fabulous stuff going on you know
at the moment I'm under under the under
the care of moorfield Hospital seeing
two different Consultants as an NHS
patient and they're brilliant you know
you think this is world-class stuff it
is but the support for them because of
you know the you know the paperwork and
so on is really not adequate and you
feel it's so it's so shocking that
really we have these Pockets but the
health service is not delivering what it
could do
and that needs really careful and
reorganization and the use of better
data to better management and you would
and as a private citizen a person that's
worked in the NHS that's given so much
to this country in terms of innovative
Health Care you would pay more tax for a
better NHS of course no question
okay Lord Winston thank you so much it
was a real pleasure and honor to meet
you so thank you so much for coming on
the show thank you thank you
Lord Winston there describing what he
and many others believe is the worst
crisis in the nhs's history
well next week we'll be asking if the
Health Service can survive I'll be part
of a special program debating the nhs's
future live from the University Hospital
in Coventry it's next Thursday the 26th
of January at 7 00 PM so do tune in and
if you'd like to be part of the live
audience at the hospital scan the QR
code on your screen right now or email
NHS crisis at Sky dot UK
now we often hear about the American
dream but what about success stories
here in Britain my next guest knows what
it's like to work your way up from the
bottom age 13 a military coup forced his
family to leave Nigeria and start a new
life in the East End of London they had
little money but against the odds that
13 year old has gone on to become
Britain's first black police and crime
commissioner earlier this week I sat
down with Festus akambo soya we
discussed his journey into the role the
racism he suffered along the way and one
of the top stories of the week trust in
policing
Professor Zach and basoya thank you so
much for coming on Beth Rigby interviews
now
you're a very interesting man with a
very interesting future you are the
country's fast uh black police and crime
commissioner what does that achievement
mean to you
for me it means that actually this is a
country where anything is possible
I remember some people saying to me with
a name like Festus and I came with
Sawyer where no one will vote for you
and they were wrong I end up winning the
highest share of votes of any police and
crime commissioner in that in that area
it just goes to show that anything is
possible Your Story begins with your
childhood growing up in Nigeria can you
explain how you and your family came to
settle in the UK when you were 13 years
old well Dad was a politician in Nigeria
and having won an election I um I know
there was a real political instability
at the time a Ministry dictator came
into into power and all the elections
were overruled so dad came to England
and we came to join in my twin sister
and and I and my mom and that was quite
a cultural shock for us I mean we lived
in a pretty affluent environment we're
very comfortable to now live in a two
bedroom flat four of us with another
family or four so eight of us and a
two-bedroom flat in Upton Park
and your dad
became
an immigrant holding down three jobs as
a cleaner yeah to make ends meet did it
hurt his prime absolutely you know but
the thing that actually taught me
was that so long as you're working hard
and you're willing to put in the effort
um you've got to do what you've got to
do to provide for your family despite
the difficulties and sometimes you've
got to start at the bottom and that's
okay I just want to talk a bit more
about your politics because you stood
for election as an MP in West Ham in
2015. why is it do you think that
ethnically diverse people in the UK that
64 of them in the according to the
recent poll polling shows that they vote
labor and 20 vote conservative I think
there's some generational
um aspect to this where people tend to
vote the way their parents voted so it's
no surprise to me that when first
generation migrants come to the UK they
sometimes see the labor party as the
party of the working people one question
was Chancellor a labor MP called him
superficially black because he was a
tory
what did that instant make you feel as a
black conservative that was
exceptionally
exceptionally
um disgusting
it was exceptionally in my view racist
and stereotyping in the worst way
because it was suggesting that to be
black you have to be able to speak a
certain way to be black you cannot go to
Eaton or Oxford or the top schools in
the world because that's not what black
people do I thought was reprehensible
the Civil report which examined racial
disparities in the UK got into hot water
when it appeared to conclude that UK
Society wasn't institutionally racist
what was what was your take on that
I can hand on heart say personally
the color of my skin has never prevented
me from achieving anything I wanted to
achieve in this country that said there
is no question in my mind that there are
racist individuals out there I get the
abuse from some of these on social media
there is one that might be coming in in
the public domain in a couple of months
to come in terms of racial abuse and
that I've received
um what do you mean
to complain about it but it was it was
quite a serious one right you know with
threats to my family it was quite a
serious one okay quite a serious one but
I'm sorry I'm sorry I mean you know Dan
Abbott faces this you know David Lammy
faces did
um quasi as you just mentioned faces
Cami faces this you know Rishi now is
facing it you know it's it's
unfortunately there are some people in
Britain who do not like to see people
with this different skin color are in
positions of influence and power Boris
Johnson has written the past I know it
was a long time ago but he did talk
about out picking the knees and
watermelon Smiles did that trouble you I
think you might have apologized for
those
um if you were to ask him again if he
will use those same language in another
book I'm sure he probably wouldn't do
that but personally
I don't there's any space there's any
room for that kind of language it's not
something I would well well let's get
back to you let's stop talking about all
these other politicians
you are as I said the fast black police
and crime system you yourself have been
stopped and searched I think at least
six times yes is that correct yeah yeah
three times in London uh when I was
growing up here once in Hertfordshire
once in buckinghamshire and once in
bedfordshire I wanted to ask you like
has it happened to your sons do you
worry for your sons
thankfully hasn't happened to know my
children yet but the thing is this I
have used because I I train to be a
special Constable breakfast before I
became a police and crime commissioner
and I got to see for myself firsthand
how the powers are used I saw this I got
to see the necessity of it and it's
something that we need that the police
need to have in their Arsenal in keeping
our communities safe
but it's not it is a blunt tool so you
support it I support the appropriate use
of it right uh and the justifiable it's
used inappropriately often sometimes
without a question of course okay wasn't
I was I think 19 years old yeah I was
coming from basketball practice in White
Chapel and my goal stopped and I asked
the officer why did you stop me and he
said to me just to make sure you know
one of London's Most Wanted
that was it
how'd you thought maybe were you angry
at the time I didn't really care because
I knew a lot of my friends dealt with
that but the older I got knowing what I
know now I'm like well that's kind of
that was just wrong there was no need
for that I just would love to see
policing also understand how its
coercive Powers have an impact on people
um who are most affected by itself
someone called you a traitor when you
took this job was that
was it painful for you but did you
understand why can you understand no I
couldn't understand why absolutely not I
mean you know I I I'm a conservative
because I want to be I know my history
as a black person I know the history of
this country I'm not in denial of it I
welcome and celebrate the good but you
know I of course I I have to accept
they're not very good as well uh but the
conservative party is not
um a
um a monolithic group for someone to
give me grief just because I'm in one
political party and dating the color of
my skin should not fit into that
political part I think it's just or was
it because because people feel that the
police is institutionally racist and
it's disproportionately targeting young
black men in stop and search Etc so
people are mistrustful well I mean I've
been call Trader for that as well you
know you know but you know my thing is
this
um I feel very passionate about Law and
Order
um but there are those who like carry
poo really are total shame to the
uniform that they wear but I'm here
because I want to make policing better
for all of our communities in London
where you grew up black londoners make
up 13 of the capital's total population
yet account for 45 of London's knife
murder victims and 61 of knife murder
perpetrators and 53 of knife crime
perpetrators this is a very
controversial one because there are some
people who would say well stop picking
on black people whatever it is but the
evidence is what it is you can't the
numbers don't lie I think there are
um issues
that need addressing
as a community but it won't be addressed
by people's fingerpoints oh well there
you go because you're black you're more
likely to be killed so I'm gonna stop
you more for any other any reason with
without whether you like it or not I
think we need to try to find the right
balance here this is one of the reasons
why I choose at some cost to me and and
my family to be as public as I am
and it's because I want those young men
uh to see that whether actually whether
they're black or white whatever the case
might be but you know you can come from
a council estate
and B where I am today yes you can be a
football player yes you can be a
musician or be a stormzy or you could be
a burner boy whatever it is you want to
be can be whatever you want to be you
know but the reality is this there is a
an underworld
that is driving a lot of this violence
and arguments which you don't really
talk about as well which does not have
the racial Dimensions or the racial
narrative which is the use of drugs
you know a lot of the stabbers a lot of
the violence are driven by the demand
for drugs in Britain which is
phenomenal
uh and you know I I would love to see
more police resources being used in
dealing with this demand side
that is also driving this violence in
our communities but not enough resources
put into this area because it is young
black boys who are suffering rather than
middle class white boys that's that's a
tricky one
um and I would know one to
um assume uh motive
but I see that a lot of effort is going
to run enforcement
on those who sell and who deal uh but a
lot less goes on dealing with the users
a huge amount of resource goes into
enforcement for those who are selling uh
but very very little goes into as
opposed to the middle class which he's
taking cocaine absolutely yeah and and
whether to demand there will be a supply
okay so you think that that is unfair
I think it's something that needs to be
looked at I need to ask you about David
the David Carrick case this week I know
he was a met officer but the case surely
has ramifications for all forces he's
not One Bad Apple is he is part of a
culture how much do you think it
undermines the police when I was given
evidence before the home Affairs select
committee I said that I am tired of
hearing this line of one bad apples we
need to stop talking about that quite
rightly damn right the public expect
there to be no bad apples
but in the real world policing because
of the nature of what it is will
unfortunately attract people who have
ulterior motives and if they can get
through that system they will be able to
manifest those things
how worried you that a man with his
record could join the police force
maintain it over many years despite all
the signs he was violent and
intimidating and he'd be invented
several times but a solution can't be
just about vetting alone because clearly
as we can see from this carry case
people who have been vetted still get
through despite evidence but we need to
also have a situation whereby people who
complain
within policing or externally are taken
more seriously and this is looked into
so in bedfordshire now since I became
PCC about seven officers have been
dismissed so are you confident that this
couldn't happen in your police force
I would be dishonest if I was to say
that could never happen because like I
said we've got seven officers who have
dismissed they are now I think about 27
live cases that they're still
investigating for bedfordshire alone but
not not all of them are like rapes or
yeah yeah there could be all kinds of
different issues misogyny racism you
name it 27 Life Cases
27 Life Cases but what I choose to do as
a police and crime commissioner which
many other pieces are doing is that I'm
holding my chief Constable accountable
every single month for this he spends
time on the front line with the officers
he gets to pick up things and already we
are seeing the benefit of that finally
um do you think that having a prime
minister from an ethnic minority Rishi
sunac our first ethnic minority and
Hindu prime minister a massive
achievement
um do you think it makes it easier or
harder for the conservative party to win
an election under him I think ultimately
will be the economy that decides what
people think I have a fulfilling their
pockets in their bank account in terms
of his ethnicity and encouraging others
uh I think sometime in this country you
know Beth we
on the state
they're really really good thing that's
happening here you know when Barack
Obama became the first black president
everybody was upping up with everybody
loved it it was a great thing but when
we have the first uh you know brown skin
you know prime minister ever in this
country uh was was the big deal you know
I think we talked down this country a
bit too much and some of our major
achievements I think we should celebrate
Britain a lot more than we do okay well
Festus thank you so much for giving me
your time today I've thoroughly enjoyed
it thank you
Festus akinbu Sawyer there now remember
that name because I'm sure that one day
Westminster will come call in for that
particular gentleman now if you scan
this QR code on screen now you can watch
all of our interviews online and all of
the previous episodes of the show
and if you scan the QR code on screen
here you can listen to the Beth Rigby
interviews podcast and new episodes
available now each week I take a look at
the highlights of the interviews have a
chat about the political week so there's
some extra bits and pieces in there too
that's on the Sky News app or wherever
you get your podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much to my guests Festus and Lord
Winston and thank you all for watching
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]